parametric's right we introduced this
idea of a parameter this other variable
a third variable that really defines
what's going on on your curve okay we
usually use a particular letter for the
parameter which is T okay so if this is
the Cartesian equation for our parabola
here right where is the pair of
parametric equations that we tend to use
of you include x equals y your course
sorry for the coordinates okay so our x
coordinate is to a tee and how y
coordinate will be is a T squared right
so this is how a pair of parametric
equations and when you Jam them together
to get rid of the trim it up to
eliminate it this is what you end up
with okay great so be that these are
coordinates we're now gonna start
thinking about a particular point on the
curve with particular parameters which
if you remember back you know how about
the unit circle the parameter refers to
the angle right what is the parameter
refer to on a parabola once it actually
telling you about such and such a place
if I said the parameter is 1 what does
that mean about that point if T is equal
one like if I said sorry okay you know
I've got a point gradient and it's
caused something sign something we know
what that something is what's the
something here what's the parabola bead
or the parabola
it's the gradient right it's the
gradient we looked at we differentiated
and then if you take these two guys
you're gonna differentiate this directly
and put in your x coordinate or you
could differentiate each of these with
respect to T jam together chain rule and
out comes the parabola okay sir we're
now look your particular points with
particular gradients they both have this
form so if I have two points that I'm
interested in P and Q is that next
available letter right to minimize the
number of things are trying to remember
we call the parameter at Point P little
beep good morning so instead of 288 e
squared this is where our parameter T
happens to have the particular value P
whatever that is so that's some constant
okay and for Q we'll do the same thing
so I've got to a cube and so we're gonna
think about equations related to these
points are related to features of the
graph that are connected to these points
we're gonna start with the simplest one
which is you've got two of them
let's try it up together right so I'm
gonna gonna be color here now because
this is the listening to both joining
two parts on a curve P right we have
another name for when you join an
interval from two parts on a curve B on
a second we call that a chord right so
on a parabola we call it exactly the
same thing
it's a chord okay so this is the chord
of a parabola and that's the chord of a
circle so what we want to find here
based on our parametric equations is
what's the equation of this Court
what is the Cartesian equation that
tells us that line that goes through P
and K now the reason why having their
pro 2 is particularly useful is because
you're not going to find out the
equation this court we want to find out
in smooth one among the two things elite
is the gradient right and therefore we
already know the gradients of these two
points so that kind of makes things a
bit easier for us right to find the
equation in this line I've only its
gradient and then I'm going to put it in
these two points I could just do 2 point
formula but 2 point formula if you
remember looks like this
which if you can't remember already
works out the gradient that is the
gradient okay so using 2 point formula
or working out with gradient by itself
is doing the same thing mathematically
okay it's just that as you'll see
working out the gradient on its own or
year us and in science so let's do this
the gradient of this core P Q right I've
got two points let's just knock this out
rise over run yeah rise over run and of
course you could put P or Q first it
would have matter it's going to
factorize out with exactly the same way
speaking of factorizing we can make this
tremendously neater than it is now right
well somebody give you some suggestions
from what I could do to that numerator
yeah Mitsu
okay we'll factor out the a good that I
can go further than that what else can I
do yeah I have difference of squares up
there don't know very good so I'm going
to do this all in one hit come here
there's my difference with skis okay see
Dominator someone else so and also to
give you suggestion what can I do to
that take out this two ways a common
factor and that just leaves me by this
cube okay now that's what I'm in right
now I am about to cancel okay how about
to cancel these two guys but you guys
know I'm trying to drill it into you
right well you've got things on a
faction on the numerator already you
just don't just cancel them out because
you can't always just kid sort things
out
I can't cancel things out here for a
particular reason now it's kind of
implied on this diagram why could I can
so people ask you yeah is it because
these two are always positive that would
be important if what I have is an
inequality because then like the
direction of the inequality wouldn't
change but now I just have equation
there's something else important to this
that is the reason why you're any
different
okay I'm kind of assuming kind of shitty
because I want a chord right I want
these two points to be not the same
point
PQ I suppose could be sitting on top of
one dollar but then this whole exercise
will be rather trivial right so I'm kind
of
he are the reason why I could get rid of
the P minus Q's is because P and Q are
not the same get ready because of course
if they were then I'd be dividing by
zero and that causes some problems all
right I've almost done it's not just the
peanuts Q I can get rid of can also get
rid of the a right which leaves me with
this so here's my gradient now just
pause right you should always do this
whenever you get a result what does this
result me remember you know a P Q R they
represent the gradients at this point
like the gradient of that tangent and be
graded at this point so I can just
quickly draw that if something like this
use your imagination and this okay the
gradient P is that right QZ so what's
half P plus Q yeah it's the average very
good very good like this is not just
some random thing it's the average of
the gradients at the ends of the cords
right the reason why I'm pointing this
out to you is for two reasons number one
it should kind of make sense right you
have a look at my two blue lines and my
green chord right you should expect that
like if you try to get the gradient of
this thing right if you make say one of
these ones make it further along okay so
that means as I go further and further
the gradient is getting steeper and
steeper more and more positive right
does that make sense well as I move this
guy further along and its gradient
increases what will happen to the
gradient of the chord it will also
increase because it's angling up like
this and it's getting steeper I'm gonna
Hannah make this for you in a second
okay so you'll see that's the first
reason secondly I want you to be able to
remember this very easily this is the
first this is gonna form the first of
many equations that you don't have to
memorize but it's helpful to know what
they are so that when you do get them
you'll be like oh yeah that's familiar I
don't want you to just speak odds random
algebra it's ready algebra it's an
average you guys
okay I have a gradient what else will I
be to get the equation of this court I
need a point okay now it just so happens
that I know two points that go through
that are on this Court okay so here's
what I'd like you to do if you're
sitting in a pair I want the left hand
person in the pair to take the left
endpoint take you okay and if you're the
right-hand person then I want you to
take the right point if you're sitting
by yourself you can pick up every bike
okay so we know it goes through both of
these points coach it out we've got the
gradient let's put into quick reading
for